das sechste große arten sterben hat er
wohl begonnen danke an die menschheit
aber gebe es dieses massensterben auch
ohne klimawandels dieser frage gehen wir
heute bei pixum tanzen fiction nach
herzlich willkommen
moment ist der klimawandel oder doch der
mensch an sich ursache des
bevorstehenden massensterben fakt ist
wenn wir menschen nicht auf der erde
leben würden wäre das artensterben 114
mal geringer das finde ich wirklich
ziemlich erschreckend so lautet das
ergebnis einer im fachmagazin science et
warnte veröffentlichten studie wenn man
sich jetzt vorstellt dass wir menschen
nur eine art von vielen auf dem planeten
sind dann sind wir wohl eher eine
naturkatastrophe als eine spezies und
die gründe gegenüber der welt berichtet
der ökologe edward wilson er kürze die
ursachen des abends sterben mit dem
kunstwort hypo ab zitat das h steht
dabei für die wichtigste ursache
inhabitat verlust das heißt also die
zerstörung des lebensraumes dass sie
steht für invasive spezies also arten
wie ihn als eingespielte ökosysteme
einbringen und die einheimischen arten
verdrängen
das erste p steht für polnischen also
für die umweltverschmutzung das zweite p
steht für population also die
bevölkerung bzw
für die über volk bevölkerung eines
lebensraumes und schließlich steht das
wofür overhage sting also die
überfischung und überlegung wie
allerorts stattfindet diese fünf gründe
haben den vergangenen jahrtausenden das
tempo des artensterbens enorm erhöht
zitat ende
den klimawandel findet man in hippo also
auch nicht direkt beim wort genannt
wieder aber auch der klimawandel schmid
jedoch eine erhebliche rolle wie wieder
andere studien beschreiben so sterben
immer mehr arten aus die nicht wärme
lieben sind aber andere arten die eben
wärmeliebende sind sie verbreiten sich
immer mehr uns verdrängen die anderen ab
neuen studien zufolge wären tatsächlich
der mensch an sich und nicht der
klimawandel als folge des menschen die
gefährliche bedrohung zitat der sich
ausbreitende mensch und nicht etwa der
klimawandel waren ursache des großfeuers
sterben so forscher der monash
university in victoria australien in der
fachzeitschrift nature communications
der mensch an sich also zerstört
beziehungsweise schränkt die
biodiversität so stark ein dass der
ganze arten vernichtet
was bezeichnet aber die biodiversität
zitat der begriff biodiversität
biologische vielfalt bezeichnet das
gesamte spektrum des lebens auf der erde
damit schießt er nicht nur die vielzahl
aller natürlich vorkommenden sowie der
gezüchteten tier und pflanzenarten
mikroorganismen und bisse ein sondern
auch die genetische vielfalt innerhalb
jeder art auch die vielfalt der
lebensräume auf der erde mitsamt ihren
komplexen ökologischen prozessen und
wechselwirkung gehören zu biodiversität
erklärt der verein biofrankfurt ev diese
wechselwirkung stört der mensch mit
seiner rasanten ausbreitung aber zunimmt
dabei spielt zum beispiel auch der
tierhandel oder eben der verzehr von
tieren eine große rolle wir menschen
treiben also das artensterben auf den
unterschiedlichsten wegen immer weiter
und werden früher oder später selbst
opfer wenn wir unter anderem durch das
artensterben unseren planeten zerstört
haben die frage ob unsere ausrotten de
lebensweise oder der von uns befeuerte
klimawandel den finalen schief setzen
wird ist also noch nicht eindeutig
beantworten was glaubt ihr ist der
mensch an sich eine größere gefahr oder
eben der klimawandel und was können wir
dagegen tun
das hängt ja von der antwort auf diese
frage ab also hier könnt ihr mir jetzt
da noch ein abo aufs auge drücken und an
der glocke läuten wenn ihr wirklich kein
video mehr verpassen wollt hier geht zu
einem weiteren video zum thema
massensterben
und jetzt heißt es abschied nehmen also
bis dann bleibt